Bitcoin other cryptocurrencies and the
crypto industry in general has garnered
a lot of interest internationally over
the last few years we've seen El
Salvador make it legal tender we have
seen a city in Switzerland make it legal
tender we have seen cities states and
Nations all around the globe
continuously work to how they can use
this Bitcoin Network and how it can help
their citizens well the next development
in this industry just came in the
European Union has decided not to ban
pow or proof of work consensus the proof
of work is a decentralized consensus
mechanism that requires members of a
network to expend energy solving and
arbitrary mathematical puzzle to prevent
anybody from gaming the system now this
is different from other types of
blockchains the other type of blockchain
that is most popular is proof of stake
that's Solana and other cryptocurrencies
run on this is different this is a proof
of work consensus that rewards
individual tools for validating
transactions and Mining new tokens
Marcus Ferber a spokesman for the Epp on
the economic and monetary Affairs
committee had a great quote he stated we
cannot lead crypto assets to scammers
and fraudsters the new rules for
cryptocurrencies will fill the existing
regulatory vacuum by putting in place a
clear framework to protect investors and
ensure Market Integrity this is ideal
quote right here this puts it and Nails
it right on the head is we cannot leave
this industry up and open for the Wild
Wild West that people have called it
recently but instead we need to create
this clear regulatory framework so that
individuals that want to help Advance
this industry and provide valuable
solutions to people all around the world
you using this technology they have
access to it and they can do that and
secondly look you don't want to ban
something you don't really understand
right so Banning something now just to
reverse it later on when it becomes more
predominant and if it becomes more
predominant in the world that's a big
deal and the last thing I want to touch
on here is all the headlines are saying
are EU legalizes Bitcoin EU legalizes
proof of work all this stuff look if
it's not illegal you don't need to
utilize it you do have to put these
Frameworks into place but let me
reiterate Bitcoin and proof of work
consensus was not illegal in the
European Union therefore they did not
make it legal they are simply just
providing some legal regulatory
Frameworks around the industry hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time